how did you get involved with this why
are you so passionate about this issue
okay thank you look I I got involved
with this through my daughter when she's
15 years of age she won a scholarship to
work in orphanages in Nepal and and
incredibly sadly we discovered that
there all the children she she looked
after were later trafficked into the sex
slavery industry and I think she had a
fairly close shave herself I then began
to investigate child sex trafficking all
around the world and before I got really
passionate about it I looked into my own
supply chains with where large company
with thousands of suppliers around the
world and unfortunately I found many
counts of slavery including South Indian
men in their thousands working in these
terrible sweatshops in the Middle East
they had no passports in the Middle East
if you try and get around without a
passport you're not local you can get
barbecued and and these people could not
escape they had a life expectancy of
less than five years that weren't paid
so and this is a big commercial
enterprise actually a British PLC was at
the top of the chain that contracted it
out and and of course this company was
making stuff for my company but also
companies all around the world
particularly those in the fortune 500
they've all got slavery in their supply
chains
okay so Andrea I'm curious you trying to
get rid of that in your supply chain how
much did that cost you and how do you
make that business case then for other
companies to put money into doing the
same thing look it's a I think there's a
fantastic business case for slavery if
you're a country or even a company if
you announce that you're going to make
sure that your supply chains of free of
modern-day slavery the big funds around
the world and global investors like
myself we start to look very hard at
investing in your company because it's
normally at the inflection point
particularly a country if a country says
I've suffered slavery therefore my value
of my countries down the value my real
estate of my industries is down but I'm
going to end slavery
that's the inflection point that be
investors start to look for because when
they enslave in that country without any
doubt that country's GDP Rises its
economic growth increases so there's a
very strong business case but that's
above of course but how much did it cost
you for Tesco it's a great question it
cost next to nothing I just sent out a
letter to all my suppliers with an
affidavit or statute declaration saying
please sign that you've investigated
your own supply chains and the supply
chains to them a first and second order
supply chains and you can assure me with
your own oath that there is no
modern-day slavery forced labor in your
supply chains and when you sign this
year also inviting me to a do a spot
ordered if ever I wish to on your
suppliers and and I got thousands of
letters back but I got about fifty which
weren't returned and I investigated some
of those and that's how I found
modern-day slavery in my supply chains
but it was it was not expensive forgive
me if I just move the conversation away
to an or which which we'd love to hear
your your viewpoint on what a wild ride
it's been back end of last year $38 a
ton April $70 now $50 Andrew what's
going on have we seen the peaks how low
can it go I'd much rather be talking
about modern-day slavery but I recognize
this is Bloomberg and you've got guys
out there if I could just say please be
aware modern slavery exists there's
enough people in modern slavery is to
fill the entire country of Spain